one could easily spend a lot of time
introducing professor jim robinson but i
won't do that i'll just do a short
introduction so we're very happy to have
uh
jim uh who's an economist and a
political scientist and currently the
pearson professor of global conflict
studies he's the university professor at
the university of chicago
and
you know he
throughout his life has done very
interesting work that involves a
combination of modeling and fieldwork
and today we'll hear about bolivia
and
in the past i've
i've heard about other places in south
america actually also the democratic
republic of the congo and from what i
gather from our conversation we might
hear about nigeria soon as well so i'm
looking forward to that too uh jim
thanks very much for joining us and
we're in a hybrid mode uh so there are
some people in the room and then some
some of us on on zoom
okay yes great thank you very much for
inviting me i'm i'm very sorry not to
not to be there some of you may i did my
phd at yale you know so
so i must i always i have a lot of
friends there and i always like like
going back to new haven
you know though it does remind me of
sometimes
perhaps i'd rather forget you know okay
so so uh yeah so you will hear about
nigeria but but but that's that's that's
far off so let me let me
let me share my screen
here we go
all right thank you very much so i'm
gonna i'm gonna talk about bolivia
indeed and um but but i'm gonna start by
sort of putting the data and the
specific research in a bigger context of
of kind of comparative development of
latin america that i have worked on for
many years and the return of pachamama
you'll see where pachamama comes in
pachamama is the
earth mother kind of very powerful
important uh deity for the andean kind
of indigenous people and this has joined
a joint project with carlos molina
carlos is a phd student in the economics
department in mit and pablo celia pablo
is a professor at the economics
department at the university of
copenhagen uh in denmark
so let me all right so let me so what's
the let me talk about
the big picture and then i'll get into
the little picture you know here's a
quote from one of the founders of the
mass political party in bolivia
uh
uh and you know he's talking about he's
talking about coca and its relationship
to pachamama so when you when you pray
to pachamama you offer you offer you
know you offer coca and other things and
gifts and sacrifices okay
so so the way we're thinking about this
project is you know there's been an
enormous amount of research i myself
have worked on this a lot kind of
inspire you know with sort of deep roots
i think the most uh obvious source of
renewed excitement in this question the
sort of comparative development of the
americas is this famous paper by
angerman and sokolov in 1997 that's
certainly i must have read that paper 30
times you know when i found it
originally it sort of blew my mind it's
a kind of economic history long run
comparative development of the americas
sort of emphasizing how colonialism
created these very different societies
in north america from south america and
that explains very different patterns of
inequality social mobility long run
development
since they they wrote there's been some
kind of much more micro work trying to
dig into the nature of latin american
institutions and latin american states
and societies the sorts of things that
anger and social have talked about i
think most famously melissa dell's
2010 paper on the mita in in potosi
where she sort of examined in some sense
the most famous extractive institution
of the colonial period the potosi meter
she looked at the catchment area the
boundaries of the catchment area of the
meter which has this huge labor draft to
the mines in in potosi and bolivia and
and she found that you know if you
compare places just inside them
just outside the meter places inside the
meter had consumption levels which were
a third less they had more child
stunting and she tells a brilliant
story about how you know that me to have
this look cast this long shadow over
you'll see in by the end by the end of
my talk why i'm emphasizing this cast
this long shadow over economic
development in peru and and bolivia
but i guess our starting point and you
know this is something that i've i've
i've come to understand from working a
lot in colombia and and you know working
a lot in rural colombia is that you know
colonial states were very patchwork
things they controlled large areas of
latin america in a very very uneven
uh way
they were indirectly ruled by casiques
by indigenous leaders in the
post-independence people by what's
called caudillos in in the historical
literature and even during the colonial
period they are separated into you know
the republic for spaniards and the
republic of the indians so indigenous
people were left
separate self-governing
and and
um
sorry to interrupt uh i'm i'm worried
that
the slides might be moving on your
screen but not on the zoom screen we
still have just the title slide on there
no no no no can you see anything now
um so we can only see the title slide um
which might you know i think your
computer might be treating us oh there
let me try again shall i try and share
again sure
so so the starting point for this paper
is you know it's it's right it's right
that you know the the the
the kind of story about extractive
institutions in latin america
exploitation of indigenous people
creation of inequality but i want to say
it's very uneven and what we're trying
to do in this paper i think is to sort
of dig into the unevenness of the state
and the control and the span of the
state and sort of illustrate that this
has interesting possibilities it's not
all negative it has positive
possibilities and i think that we think
that's the story in bolivia i changed
the slide can you see that
so so so large parts of
colonial latin america and post-colonial
latin america were kind of organized you
could say in this republic of the
india's were
many of the indigenous institutions
persisted okay match much of the
cohesion of indigenous society
persistent and the word that we like is
you know moral economy so this is the
you know this is the word that this is a
phrase that ep thompson the british
historian applied to thinking about 18th
century british society the moral kind
of moral economy the set of rules and
norms and practices that were really
outside of the colonial state and
outside of the post-colonial state and
as james scott you know uh argued in his
famous book the moral economy of the
moral economy of the peasant
when these moral economies are
challenged they can react
okay and that you know the the i'm going
to just one give one colombian example
usually i talk far too much about
colombia but one colombian example which
i always like just to kind of illustrate
this is you know colombia is famous for
being at one point the you know the drug
the kidnapping the murder capital of the
world you know and
and
in the story of latin american sort of
deep inequality and development
divergence that emanates magnum and
so-called there's a lot of emphasis on
elites and i think rightly so but i
think what you have to recognize is that
the hegemony of elites is perhaps over
emphasized in a lot of this research
including in my own research because in
colombia it wasn't colombian elites that
wanted to turn the country into the
drug-running
homicide and kidnapping capital of the
world they just couldn't stop it why
couldn't they stop it because they
didn't control large parts of colombia
there were large vacant spaces vacuums
where
where other elites could emerge and
other political projects could emerge
and that's
that's an interesting and and kind of
positive thing at least we'll try to
argue maybe not in the colombian case
now here's an example of of you know not
being able to control half of the half
of colombia here's three uh paramilitary
warlords you could say
ernesto baez on the left salvatore
mancuso in the middle and ramon sasa on
the right you know what are they doing
they're in
congress with suits on you know
negotiating with the politicians so so
you don't control the periphery you you
negotiate with it and and that's that's
a different image i think from a lot of
this work kind of emphasizing sort of
hedge very hegemonic elites okay so so
so in this project what we're going to
do is is study
what we think of as the violation of the
moral economy in rural bolivia so so
this moral economy you know deeply
rooted in the pre-andean past kind of
reproducing itself through the colonial
period through the post-colonial period
in some sense you know to quote see
c.l.r james's book on the haitian
revolution
it was a volcano waiting to to go off he
uses this metaphor that the the french
in haiti were was sleeping on the edge
of vesuvius okay it was sitting there
the volcano was waiting to go off it
didn't go off for hundreds of years but
then it did go off and i think that's
the way we sort of want you to think
about what's happened in bolivia in the
last 20 years the volcano went off and
there's been a tectonic change in the
nature of politics and society okay and
and so we're going to look at that be
living experience but i want you to sort
of think more broadly that you know
perhaps we haven't conceptualized
properly the nature of the state in
latin america very uneven control of
much of its territory and the sort of
possibilities that perhaps that allows
for that we haven't grasped including
possibilities for dramatic change which
is what we've seen in bolivia okay so
what set off the volcano in bolivia well
our argument is it's basically
the eradication of coca
remember you have to use coco to honor
pachamama in 1997 hugo banzo who was the
president struck a deal with the united
states aiming at i say sometimes or we
say sometimes zero coca the reason we
say sometimes is that it's a little
uneven if you look at all the documents
of you know that this there's
it's it's a little uneven what was going
on and different documents say different
things but the basic thrust of it seems
to have been president banza agreed to
eliminate coca okay so what we're going
to look at in the data is the
consequence of this cocoa eradication
for politics in bolivia and the kind of
consequent social consequences that
that's had that that that is had okay
but i think to grasp you know why we're
looking at coca and the and the kind of
political consequences of the attempt to
eradicate coca it's good to sort of this
is what they you know if you're
colombian and you say eradicate coke you
think of helicopters and planes sort of
spraying but this is how they do it in
bolivia with a with a machete so just uh
you know just to give you the picture
and you know here's just you know some
sense the paper in the nutshell we're
gonna get much more into different
things
here is uh the drug eradication money on
the left-hand axis coming flowing from
the united states that ramps up with
this plan dignidad uh
ironically named the plan dignitad you
know that bans the signs of the u.s
government so there's a huge ramping up
of
counter-narcotics aid here's the voucher
of the mass political party i'll talk a
little bit about mass
the origins of mass are very complicated
you know it was organized by the
kokoleros by these coca farmers in the
chaparrae valley in the east of bolivia
but there's many other groups involved
in it to start with leftist groups
women's groups indigenous groups so let
me not get into the detailed history you
could sort of say this
united left party was a kind of will
that evo morales was involved with was a
sort of you know kind of anticipated a
little bit the first time mass really
runs as a party is in 1999 and then you
can see the vote share rockets up and
they capture uh the president morales
wins the presidential election 2005.
then of course you know he abandons the
counter narcotics policy so aid with us
with us away so what we're going to be
mostly interested in is this period here
of
the kind of the impact of this counter
narcotics program on political support
for mass
and then what were the consequences
which
came that some of the consequences as a
result of this capture of the state
which happens in 2005 okay so so i think
i think it you know it's it's it's i
think you know but anyone who's been in
bolivia in rural bolivia will kind of
know this already but but but you know
as an englishman as you know the the the
idea of you know to give you an analogy
an english analogy of of um you know
what would it be like you know what's
the analogy in england of like banning
coca in bolivia it would be like banning
beer you know if you ban beer and close
down all the pubs you know what what
would england what would english men you
know what would english people do
so i mean and that's a sort of trivial
i guess that's a bit trivial really
because coco is just much more deeply
embedded in the culture and the
religious and the world view of of
andean
people okay so here's alan kolata who's
a colleague of mine at the university of
chicago who's uh who's a a very
important scholar of this part of the
world and of indigenous society talking
about
the most important sort of
institutionalization
of indigenous society amongst the imara
people in in in bolivia so of course
bolivia is very complicated very it's
very heterogeneous uh ethnic ethnically
the in the andean area the most
most the largest number of people are
imara or quechua so so the iu is the the
kind of name for a local local aymara
community okay so here he's just
describing what the iu is you know
principles of common identity
uh let me move this thing so i can read
it for you principles of common identity
are mobilized around and deeply
sedimented through interpersonal
intimacy derived from shared history
shared labor shared meals shared worship
of a common ancestor so there's an
enormous amount of kind of cooperative
behavior
uh very sort of communal uh
many very famous reciprocal institutions
of labor sharing collective collective
activity for building houses cooking
providing public goods and in fact you
have one of the most famous scholars of
this enrique mayer at in the
anthropology department at yale so
you're in a great place if you want to
learn more about this but but so so the
the iu and the marker is the the
analogous quechua institution is the
sort of main way that indigenous
societies organized and i think most of
the scholars of this see this as very
historical okay so this is part you
could say of this story i was telling
you the republic of the india was you
know this immense persistence of this
rural organization of indigenous people
and many of the practices and beliefs
over time and i want to say that you
know
this is very connected with coca so
catherine allen who's an anthropologist
at george washington university has
written a lot about this about how you
know it's one thing to say you know
there's labor reciprocity you know you
help me i help you but i don't do
anything without and i don't ask
anything from you without offering coca
with what they call kintu i have to
offer you three cocolese if you've
worked in west africa it's like cola
cola and palm wine you know if you want
to do anything or talk to someone or
meet someone or you break cola and you
have palm wine so here it's coca and you
know and cane cane liquor nowadays
that's not very historic i guess chicha
or something would have been more
historic but kane liquor is kind of more
more more practical perhaps nowadays and
i won't go into this in gen
i'm just you know in i'm just throwing
it up there i'm not going to read it
just to say you know coco is just
cements everything is coca people
exchanging coco coca giving coca it's
just absolutely central to people's
lives okay so so i think when when you
understand that you see how kind of
crazy this
trying to abolish coca and make coke not
just eradicate coco but make coca
illegal that you know like this is just
an enormous violation of this
moral economy that's that's the argument
here okay and here's here's pablo you
know doing into when we were doing field
work last year so so i mean i this is
the sort of thing where when you do
field work you just kind of you just
this just really hits you you know and
it it it brings home the sort of how
central this is to people's lives and
and the way they think about about
things so so so i i regret that that
superficial analogy to englishman
drinking beer this is this is much more
serious than important than that
okay so so you know
there's a deep oh you know again there's
a very rich secondary literature about
the rise of the mass and the
organization of the mass and the
connection between the mass and the iu
and these indigenous organizations so so
it's very there's very kind of
there's very interesting work by
bolivian scholars looking at that you
know so let me not dwell on that but
many leaders of the mass many many many
representatives of the mass in national
institutions or local institutions
they have roots in the iu and the marker
they've served you know in executive
positions they have very interesting
political institutions the iu and the
marker they kind of rotate every year uh
everyone sort of takes it in turn to do
different positions within the hierarchy
different executive positions and then
it's a very kind of democratic uh
republican type of thing but i won't go
into that okay so just to say
it's well documented this connection
between these indigenous institutions
and the mass
okay so so so what what what's the
what's just to kind of anticipate the
results and i'll talk about what data we
use to talk about this
uh
uh what i'm going to show you to start
with remember that picture there's this
ramping up of counter narcotics aid and
there's this ramping up of the mass vote
share what i'm going to show you to
start with is that there's a very close
connection between
coker not actual coker but coker
suitability and the mass vote share so
in places that are suitable for coca uh
i'll explain how you we measure that in
a minute
the mass vote share goes up
differentially when planned dignidad
comes into operation so empirically you
know the way to think about this is
we're going to take plan dignidad as a
sort of shock aggregate shock affecting
bolivia
and then we're going to look at how
that interacts with your coca
suitability
much more
much more interesting is we have a very
detailed information on where these ius
are in bolivia so
more broadly where indigenous land is so
so so indigenous people have been able
to kind of claim
rights to their traditional lands in
bolivia and so we have a map of that so
we can actually look not just at coca
suitability but something much more
interesting which is do we see a
differential
increase in the vote share of the mass
when planned dignidad comes in
in places where there are the iu okay
and the answer is yes and i and none of
this is confounded by
the development effect so you might
think oh everyone's going coco growing
coca when did the digni dad comes in uh
that's a big negative shock so of course
you know that there's a there's a
political reaction to a negative
economic shock so
we're going to it's not none of what i'm
saying is confounded by that so we can
control for that and the other thing
which is sort of fascinating uh for
someone who works a lot in africa is
that this doesn't seem to be about
ethnicity uh either so you know the
ethnic political geography of bolivia is
extremely complicated as as i talked
about earlier but
but this
none of this is confounded by by you
know it's not being driven by ethnicity
uh in any way i'll tell you how we how
we control for that okay so so so so
there seems to be a significantly lot
that you know there's a significant
differential impact of this clan
dignidad on the mass vote share in
places where
which are coker suitable and more
interesting where the iau is okay so we
can look at that in a in a panel data
setting but also because we have this
map we can actually do i'll show you the
regression discontinuity results that we
can look at the boundary of the iu
and what i'm going to what i'm going to
show you is that there's large jumps in
the mass vote share when i look at kind
of inside that i just inside the i o
boundary and just outside so we have a
couple of ways of identifying of trying
to identify the causal effect of of this
okay and then what are the consequences
of that so so that's just sort of trying
to show there's this you know coco it
kind of violates this moral economy and
then there's a massive organizational
society which
which which elites can't stop you know
they can't stop and they capture the
state what happens when they capture the
state and
we're going to look at two strategies
one is social mobility of indigenous
people using data from the latino
barometry
there's a significant increase in
actual and expected rates of social
mobility for indigenous people when the
mass come to power and i think
most interesting
is we managed to collect uh six million
uh uh
birth records so we actually have the
names that people give their children
and what we can show is that there's an
enormous increase it's a 75
uh increase in the incidence of people
giving their children indigenous names
okay so so so we want to say we call
that the empowerment effect that
indigenous people instead of call giving
their children spanish names are now far
more likely to be giving them indigenous
names so to us that's a sort of reflects
the fact that this political change is
really creating a kind of inclusive
social change which i think anyone who
goes to bolivia you know you don't it
sort of hits you in the face if you're
in el alto or even in la paz spreading
into la paz so so that we're going to
document that in a couple of ways okay
um i don't know how we get i it's
difficult to manage questions and
comments in a in a seminar like this i
don't know uh
mushvik if you have a kind of
what you think's optimal i could stop
without people ask questions or i could
just kind of plow ahead and finish you
know before the end
actually if there are good places to
pause and ask you know give people 20
seconds like you like you're doing right
now that's great uh but but it's also
not a regular econ seminar in the sense
that there's people from all different
disciplines where they're used to
waiting until the end so if you could
okay uh if you if you know as long as
there are no not too many questions
right now if you can wait till the end
that's fine too if you're getting okay
yeah so i'm gonna i'm gonna talk a
little bit about the data now and i'll
talk about i can i you know i'll try to
leave
at least 20 minutes at the end for
people to ask questions is that is that
good okay all right so so so let me just
plow on and talk about the data so
we you know the main
the start of the talk the main outcome
variable is going to be votes for the
mass we can either do total number of
votes or vote share it doesn't matter
and
we have this data in a very
disaggregated form so we have voting
table data so we have the data at the
individual voting tables
uh we haven't been able to get that for
all elections but we've been able to get
it for uh
for these elections here so 1999 2004
2005 2009 2010 so we're going to use in
the regressions i'm going to show you
we're going to use total number of votes
for the mass
at the voting table okay so here what
does that look like that's that's that's
what all the voting tables look like in
bolivia so it's very disaggregated and
we're going to situate the voting table
in a sort of pixel that's kind of 10 by
10 kilometer
uh square
uh and we're going to measure you know
different things in that square such as
you know coco suitability such as
presence of presence of the iu
just to give you uh i showed you the
aggregate mass vulture you know just to
give you a sense of you know how that
changes over time you can see you know
in 1999 when they first really run as a
comp this is the chaparri valley uh you
know where the coca-leiros first got
organized so the the mass vote kind of
ramps up
you know in this part of cochabamba and
the department and then you know they
after that then you know this is when
2005 whenever wins the presidential
election you know you can see it's much
more widespread but darker red means you
know hut more vote share between 50 and
100 so this is you know very much kind
of in the altitude
coca suitability is using you know data
that people use a lot to measure
different types of crop suitability uh
in economics it's very popular nowadays
the fao have this database and for coca
you know they it it sort of it gives
you know what they call optimal or
absolute
conditions you know like
for growth you know temperature rainfall
elevation slope et cetera so so that
gives you a kind of interval you know so
for example for temperature you know the
optimal temperature for growing coca
would be 18 to 20 degrees
centigrade but but absolutely you know
there's a bigger they call as like a
bigger window there's a bigger interval
of temperatures so what we do is we just
take that data and we kind of focus on
absolutely it does doesn't matter so far
it you know that's this seems to be
robust to doing it with with with
optimal uh and you know we just
basically say you know if you take a
five kilometer by five kilometer kind of
grid cell and you know if it's if you if
you're absolute you know if you're in
the interval for temperature rainfall
elevation slope etc then that's a one
you know so that that five by five
kilometer
uh
grid cell is is is good for growing coca
and then we average it up to 10 by 10
which is the
which is what we're using kind of 10 by
10 kilometer pixel or grid cell around a
polling station so you know for this is
what it looks like so the darker here is
you know the most suitable for growing
uh for growing cocoa you know up again
tends to be like not completely in the
outer cloud it has to be down a little
bit warmer you know the chaparri or the
young gus is down so it's too cold up in
the up in you know el alto to grow coca
you have to be down a bit but of course
there's large area along the eastern
side of the seattle here which is which
is which is which is highly suitable for
growing coca okay so we have this date
from the us government on the counter
narcotics aid i kind of you know that's
very standard i showed you what that
looks like just on that that chart
before so i won't talk about that in too
much detail and you know we have this
wonderful map here it is of of
the iu you know as i said the iu is a is
imara is the imara word for this you
know uh but more broadly communal land
okay so so so there's a bit of slippage
i'm being a little bit naughty here but
just to kind of clarify what we're going
after because for example down here if
you can see my cursor this would be
guarani people you know this is not i'm
imara or quechua people living down here
on the board with paraguay so so you
know so that so what i'm going to show
you today is we're going to use all of
this but you can see that so we can map
this onto these 10 by 10 grid cells but
you know we can also do this regression
discontinuity design i guess which which
probably is more convincing as a way of
trying to identify the causal effect of
of of the impact of this plan digni dad
on on
you know on the vote share of the the
mass
okay so
yeah and we're gonna you know we're
going to control i don't want to talk
too much about development i mean i
think we you know we want to say
this is not really a story about
development you know it's not that uh
you know you're growing coca uh you you
know you're going croco
they they eliminate your coca crops you
know they come with the machete they cut
it down that's a huge negative shock so
of course you know you vote against the
government okay but what i'm going to
show you actually you know this is very
nice in the regression discontinuity
results is that you know even in places
which are completely unsuitable for
cocoa you have this very significant
treatment effect of being in the iu okay
so so people who are clearly not
involved in the you know up in the
altitude who are clearly not growing
coca
they also vote
massively in favor of mass when this
plan comes in why you know because this
is just an affront to theirs to their
society
okay so so this is mostly trying to
control for development or nightlight
it's just trying to really show you
that's not a confounder here because if
you know this literature you know then
you might think well
you know
okay so and then there's usual stuff you
know latitude not interacted with time
dummies so we're not going to go into
that okay
let me talk about that when i come to
talk about social mobility so so the
first part of the data is just using a
very canonical panel data model so so
you know so so this is why i t is going
to be total number of votes for mass at
you know polling station i in t and t
are these you know these these waves of
elections that we have and then there's
polling station fixed effects as time
effects and then we have
dt is this total this is this kind of
aggregate shock it's this total amount
of u.s drug eradication aid aid and
inverted commerce i guess you could say
ci is this index of coca suitability you
know in the pixel around a polling
station i and a i is going to be
in these first regressions the
proportion of land in that pixel which
is held by the iu or indigenous
communities okay so so so we want to see
if there's you know there's that there's
differential effects and then we can
also look at the triple the triple
interaction here
uh
okay so so so so let you know so here's
like here's the here's the results which
are most interesting i think so let me
just jump to the results that are most
interesting so so what do we find here
well we find we find a significant
positive effect of coca suitability on
you know number of votes for mass on the
left-hand side okay so so we find that's
very robust you know down here there's
all sorts of different covariates we can
play with
and i guess what i want to say here is
that you know when you control for
nighttime lights i mean you could say
this is a bad you know this would be a
bad control in the anguished and pishki
sense but but but anyway i think in this
context it's interesting to look at
whether that's the channel and you know
that does nothing to the to the
coefficients that we're interested in
you see this positive significant effect
for coca suitability and also for
community land and the the the triple
the triple remember so so just to
emphasize here
these these coefficients are the
coefficients on the interaction between
this aggregate u.s drug kind of aid
and
your coca suitability and you know the
proportion of iu or community land
within that grid cell okay so that's
like a double interaction so this is
like the triple interaction but you know
that's it's we never find that to be be
sort of significant okay so so yeah
coker suitability matters you know why
does coca suitability matter i think i
think you know the way we're thinking
about that is that that's sort of
picking up in some sense the the you
know the sort of spur you know the kind
of
location of this coca
coca culture but but but the but the but
of course the presence of the iu
or community land for us is much more
interesting because that's really
showing you know where this
institutionalized indigenous society is
you know irrespective of coca
suitability you find this positive
significant effect on the mass vote
share when
clan dignidad comes into operation okay
and if you look at the kind of
quantitative effects of this
you know you see that you know one
standard like so so if you know just to
think about what the plan digni dad did
uh you know it increased
us counter drug money by about 2.3
standard deviations at its maximum and
what we find for example with uh with
with the iu is that you know uh when
that comes in uh uh you know a one
standard deviation in u.s counter drug
aid leads to a 10
increase in the number of votes for mass
okay so so given the increase in the so
this is quantitatively very large that's
what i want to show so given the
increase in u.s counter drug aid the net
effect of these two forces here is very
big the quant quantitatively very big
yes
i have a
clarification question in your
regression do you have the
because you didn't show them in the
table the direct effect of
coca stability and that you
um
without the interaction with that with
the
plan dignitas no god that's absorbed in
the fixed effect isn't it oh you get
time invariant right okay
yeah so it's absorbing the fixed effect
okay and i want to say this is not a
simple story of the rise of ethnic
politics either so what we do is we took
the ethnologue
map which has you know which has
basically very detailed information uh
on the presence of different
ethno-linguistic groups really coded
from language that's my understanding
but we can map that onto the 10 by 10
grid cell and so we can control for the
presence of different ethnicities aimera
quechua guarani or whatever you know
that again that's a time invariant thing
but kind of interactive with time
dummies so this is not just you know
this is not confounded by the rise of
you know imara politics or the rise of
quechua politics you know and in fact
these institutions really go across
ethnic groups you know especially
quechua naimara uh in a sort of
fascinating fascinating way so i i could
get into that in more detail but i think
that's probably
not emphasized enough at the moment at
the moment you know this is not just
this is not you know you might think oh
you know it's sort of indigenous people
have finally got mobilized and you know
so this is the rise of ethnic politics
or something but that's that's not the
story we want to say we want to say this
is about this violation of this moral
economy
okay so so so all right so so now we can
do this so that's the very kind of
straightforward panel data approach to
this we could do something a little bit
more sophisticated since we have the map
which is you know we can narrow in on
the boundaries of these iu and try to
compare places just inside the iota just
outside the iu so so so the the kind of
the analogous model econometric model
that seems sort of closest to what we
estimated in the panel data model you
know is as follows so think think of you
know think of a i as just being the kind
of the distance you know of a particular
polling so now again we're thinking
about the polling stations right because
yit is again going to be the votes of
the mass party so we want to we're going
to ai like the running variable is the
distance from the polling station to the
boundary if you like and then you know
so this is the there's a very similar
kind of expression to what we had before
but just sort of introducing this
regression discontinuity type
uh model okay but think of the you know
these the the variables the same dt is
the
aggregate counter drug aid you know uh
ci is your coca suitability
and a i is the iu so here we you know we
really want to i guess we're you know
we're this is you know coco suitability
goes into the background here we're
really focusing on that map and thinking
about you know what can we say at the
boundary of the iu you know do we see
significant jumps in the vote share for
mass at at the boundary okay and the
answer to that is yes so here's a nice
picture so imagine i narrow in to
to places that are not coker suitable
okay so forget about coca well don't
forget about coco but forget about
growing coca okay and here's the
boundary and this is the mass vote show
when i go from you know being outside
the iu to being inside the highest so
what we find is a significant jump in
the mass vote share
when you when you know if it if the
polling station is inside the
inside the iu okay so so what's nice
about these results if i show if i show
you the table is that you know the the
estimated coefficients are extremely
similar to the
to the to the basic panel data
regressions like you know we think that
we try to do this in a way which makes
it as comparable as possible you know of
course there's a lot of robustness
exercises here you know in terms of how
you specify
the running variable and you know so we
you know this is that's different you
know so here this is just you know think
about this is the kind of full sample if
you think what i showed you before
obviously you lose a lot of the
observations now we're kind of zooming
in on the boundaries of this of this of
the map you know the boundaries of the
iu comparing pony stations just inside
just outside we're going to lose a lot
of polling stations that are not you
know not close or not anywhere near to
these boundaries but the the pattern
here is very
similar we don't find the triple
interaction to be i don't know why we
even have that there really
we thought it was interesting at some
point you know that you know it's like
there's all this path dependence in
papers so so you know here's something i
want to really kind of emphasize you
know which is this interaction between
the counter narcotics and the iu you
know so so this is
yeah so that pattern is very similar so
you know these results are very similar
they're just kind of dropping a lot of
observations but they're zooming in on
places where we think it's you know
there's there's kind of more
identification and we find something
very similar and it's very robust to
sort of messing about with different
specifications of the running variable
different bandwidths and things like
that
with the all the usual kind of
trade-offs okay so so so let me let me
talk a little bit about the consequences
then and then i'll shut up okay so so we
we we look at two things uh and you know
we could look at more things but but but
and i think the second thing is more is
more interesting so let me go first over
this the the first thing we look at is
just social mobility so how do we look
at that well the latino barometro asks
questions about it asks questions you
know about where you are on an income
scale okay so so it asks you to put
yourself on an income scale between one
to ten it's on an earlier slide you know
i think it's one to ten could be zero to
ten uh it asks you to put your parent on
that scale and it asks you to put your
child on that scale too so it's sort of
anticipations of the social mobility of
your children you know i can we can look
at you know do you do you expect your
children to have higher be higher up
this income scale than than than you are
okay and and so you know it's latino
bana metro so it's not a panel uh it's a
sort of repeated cross-section so you
know we're interested in you know this
sort of individual eyes response to this
income question
in municipality m at time t
we can put we don't have individual
fixed effects because it's not a panel
but we can put municipality fixed
effects in and we can look again at you
know aggregate drug counter narcotics
aid and i'm sorry when that's not what
we're going to do at all we're going to
look at i should we should change the
notation here dt is not counter
narcotics say forget that we're looking
at the consequences now so dt is a dummy
which is just switches on when evo uh
wins the 2005 presidential election okay
so now we're trying to that we're trying
to look at the consequences of this for
indigenous people okay so i
capital i imt is self-reported ethnicity
in the latino barometro so you know so
that's the dummy one if the person
reports being indigenous okay so we're
interested in whether when evo comes to
power you see differential social
mobility of indigenous people okay and
what's the answer well uh
here's the answer for you this is your
own reported in income okay so so
whenever comes to power you know
comparing before and after what you see
and you know
indigenous to non-indigenous people you
see a significant uh increase in
people's reported uh
income so so so so so this is you know i
don't know if this is social mobility uh
but this is social work it's an expected
social cruelty that's the significant
and you know much much larger
quantitatively uh
increase in your expectations the
expectations of indigenous people about
where their children are going to be on
this scale okay and there's an
interesting sort of placebo here you can
do which is we have questions on your
parents so so there's no way that you
know ever coming to power could affect
where your parents were you know most
likely seems plausible and then we don't
find anything on that so so that's kind
of nice because it's like a placebo it
sort of makes the other results more
believable it's not that
everything is kind of moving i'm sort of
euphoric so so i'm kind of
overestimating everything no nothing
happens with with with parents but you
know and i guess this is what we think
is most interesting then you see
increased expectations of indigenous
people whenever comes to power of of
social mobility measured
in this way okay then one the final
exercise before i shut up is to sort of
say
uh and remind you what the big picture
is is you know so we have six million
records of uh
the
names that people gave to their children
so what we what we don't what we're not
able to do is link parents to children
okay so you know some sense the ideal
regression that we'd like to run is you
know if i took the name of the child and
we could you know so we basically what
we did was we classified using a kind of
standard list in bolivia was this an
indigenous name or you know was it a
spanish name
and we'd like to capture you know we'd
like to measure you know was was child
eye in municipality in time t did that
post did that child get an indigenous
name and you know we'd like to know
whether their family was indigenous you
know and then we'd like to look at the
interaction between uh but we can't do
that because we can't link so we don't
know the identity we have these records
of naming but we don't have the identity
you know or the of the or the name of
the parent okay so what we have to do is
something much less nice which is you
know we do have the names of all these
children so what we're going to do is we
average them at the level of the
municipality
uh we don't know what their what their
parents were but from the sense who
their parents were but from the census
we can recover estimates of number of
indigenous people at the municipality so
so we you know so this is comes from
this is coming from the center so the
left-hand side is coming from this
six million observations of children's
names the right-hand side is coming from
the census but it's at the municipality
level you know unfortunately and then we
can interact that with this dummy of evo
coming to power we can control for time
effects and municipality fixed effects
okay and here's a picture which is very
nice okay so so you can see there's no
pre-trends here uh
when eva comes to power 2005 what you
see is you know a systematic increase in
uh in in in people you know
subject to this you know we don't really
have the micro data that we'd like but
subject to that caveat
there's there's seems to be something
going on here in terms of
a much larger proportion of
people indigenous people start naming
their children
with indigenous names and as i said you
know so so that that's what the
regression looks like and and and
quantitatively uh so so you know we
don't have six million observations here
because we're operating at this
municipality
level unfortunately so we had to average
uh um
you know and quantitatively it's very
large as i said you know so we can do
this is just like looking at the
fraction this is like the total number
of children with indigenous names and
you know quantitatively the effect is
very large so that so the effect is
about the treatment effect is about 75
percent of the mean in terms of like the
you know the fraction of children that
have indigenous names to start with okay
so so so so yeah let me there's just
there's more stuff here but let me you
know we can just do sort of this is just
like placebos and just kind of thinking
about it let me let me try to wrap up
here so when i started i talked about uh
and kind of say you know why i think
this is interesting you know there's
this
kind of hegemonic narrative of latin
american development
latin american development for
comparative development within the
americas and i think it's not wrong you
know i think melissa's results for
example
you know i believe the results but i
think what this experience in bolivia
shows is that this equilibrium is
actually a lot more fragile than it
appears when you read this literature
that once you start thinking and
understanding a bit about the kind of
architecture of the state in latin
america
large parts of bolivia you know were
sort of not really controlled by
passenger elites you know they were
controlled by indigenous institutions an
indigenous society by the iu and the
marker and with very little
hegemonic control of uh from from la paz
or anywhere else and that's true in
colombia it's true in in all sorts of
parts of latin america so that that
equilibrium can be perturbed in in in in
kind of very interesting
ways and that's exactly what happened in
this one instance you know we're we're
kind of looking at a very specific
perturbation in that equilibrium a kind
of policy that enormously disrupted the
worldview or the values if you like of
indigenous society and led to this very
powerful political reaction that
captured the state and led to you know
good things i think you know uh more
inclusive things indigenous empowerment
empowerment of women you know also we
don't really have results on that here
but if you've been in bolivia you know
women are very empowered in interesting
ways in in in bolivia in in traditional
society
and and and today you know in the
markets in el alto and everywhere else
so
so i think you know
the reason i like this paper is that
it's sort of
there's a there's a there's a there's a
silver lining to the cloud to the latin
american cloud it seems and you know
where there's one silver lining there
may be more you know just to finish by
talking about melissa's paper again the
ironic thing is that a lot of this
action is actually happening in exactly
these meter areas where she studied and
in fact francisco toledo who was the man
who kind of laid out the the meter who
was the viceroy who laid out the meter
and kind of set up that catchment area
one thing he did was to abolish all
restrictions on coco growing you know so
so so so there's an interesting
connection to the meter and francisco de
toledo so so so i'm let me shut up now
i'm happy to ask answer questions about
the econometrics if people want to go
back to that or answer questions about
about kind of anything
ah thanks very much jim so um we do have
some time so just open it up and maybe
you could use the hand raised feature if
you'd like or just unmute yourself and
speak
and if there's multiple questions then
we'll start using the handrails feature
i have a question so do we know
what what was the source of increase in
income for uh
it seems like these areas were also
doing better was it was it because of
nationalization of mining that happened
in bolivia
and it seems uh
do we know the reason for that uh was it
a transfer from this from the from the
government to the uh
uh
yeah the survey doesn't reveal that the
survey just asks you know it asks you to
place yourself for example on this scale
between
you know so it there
i think there are other questions about
occupation so not not anticipating not
and not the anticipated occupation of
your children
but it might be
we might be able to look at that you
know the the
the data that we have or we've been
using doesn't directly speak to that
um
but
but but you know i mean the reason that
i like these naming um
regressions the bet more than the social
mobility questions is you could say well
when evil came to power uh you know
maybe there's patrick patronage you know
there's there's kind of there's you know
there's patronage for indigenous people
or something so it could be that you
know it's easier to get a job in the
government if you're an indigenous
person so that you know that could be i
guess you could say that could be that
could potentially be driving these uh
results on income so maybe that's a
mechanism you had in mind uh so
you know that's not the sort of
interpretation that we that we sort of
like so i think that that's why the
naming results are better but i i we
could dig more on that but off the top
of my head i can't really say
too much about too much about that
also the area where mas is getting a
good support is also an area that
overlaps with the lithium production and
that is a big issue in bolivia in a
southwest uh
area
yeah but yeah yeah i don't i don't know
much about the organization of these
mining economies or
how that that money is redistributed i
don't know if that's very capital
intensive what's creating employment or
the rents accrue to the state and the
state is redistributing
uh you know we have these time effects
here i you know i i you know i and this
is this is a differential effect for
kind of indigenous people so i think
that
you know if it's not it i don't think a
boom you know in bolivia as a
consequence of say mineral natural
resource prices can really be driving
these results i guess i would say
okay thank you
jim
i have a question if i may
so so the paper is really interesting
and as it's interesting all these issues
about uh
how uh
societies in in latin america
have been shaping up and how
uh where the excess inequality or the
large inequality can latin america come
from i i really liked all the nuances
that you pointed out
too
and how the colonial history and
evolution all that
um
it's also a very important moment to
look at these things you know if you
look at what was happening in latin
america before
uh before the um
pandemic between chile and colombia with
the social arrests
that many linked to the
absence of
community
power community organizations that
where
citizens could feel represented
so all that is is nice it's interesting
what i'm left a little bit uh
hesitant
on embracing your conclusions
is
fine this is what happened in bolivia
where
the indigenous
background is very strong and very
prevalent
in most of latin america you cannot
think
of something similar
happening you know you know one way to
interpret what you were saying and i
particularly like the regressions where
the results were
these coca suitability yeah it's
important but it's not the story the
very story is to be inside or outside
that that structure
um that i do
but you know uh can you think of other
situations in latin america where
this community level
empowerment
can take place because i have a very
hard time to you know at least for the
countries i know best which are
uh you know cheetah and colombia and to
extend mexico although maybe mexico
there might be something like this
yeah i think i think i think that's
right i mean i think you're you know
you're right that in some sense i would
say the reason that this took
this very kind of interesting and much
more inclusive form is because you have
this very cohesive indigenous society
you know which is you know and and
that's not true in rural colombia you
know that it's true in little pockets of
narina or whatever it is or putumayo but
generally speaking it's not true in
rural colombia so so but i i guess i
would say you know i think i think the
broader point that that this literature
has sort of emphasized the hegemonic
control of elites and there's actually
all these spaces for kind of alternative
political projects to kind of emerge and
flourish you know i think that's true
you know if you think about paranism you
know think about the history of the
petronism that was kind of exactly that
you know like the the the the des
camisados you know who were the
descamisados you know they were people
from the interior you know the they were
people from the interior who kind of
mobilized who went to support you know
like that's again you might think well
that that that turned out to be a
disaster you know but but i i you know i
don't have a theorem about
when political mobilization turns into
something you know that may well be very
conditional on the nature of these
traditional bolivian institutions i
agree with that yeah well what you're
saying with your story then could be red
is to say the situation in latin america
is characterized by these big um
these big holes that can be filled
by
by
something
but you know that's that's the story in
the united states isn't jackson turner's
thesis about the frontier all about how
you know it's the frontier that creates
the the cult that you know the cape
creates the society you know it's it was
the u.s frontier with frontier expansion
and social mobility and democracy and
whatever it was that actually created
the u.s not the core you know so so i
think trying to think more about the you
know i agree with you it's a very
specific it's specific to the maybe you
can think about this in peru or a few
other places or guatemala or whatever
you know but but i you know i agree like
many of these mechanisms are going to be
different in different contexts and
rural colombia is very different from
and you know from rural
bolivia but but i i think like the
bigger the bigger image i'd like to i
tried to sort of project at the start i
find kind of interesting
uh but but but but you know whether
what's external validity of any of these
things no it's very conditional on on
these institutions and you know but i
think
you know that's
that's why i'm not an economist anymore
can i can i ask a question about the
global mobilization of indigenous people
i believe there's 47 indigenous peoples
in the world now i noticed last week
at the u.n um
summit food summit that the indigenous
peoples were part of the lobby
for
zero hunger
and my other question is this
um
within the catholic church there was a
pope john paul ii was a saint who told
the united nations in 1995
in washington
in new york at the german assembly uh in
this uh in this century
we need to have a universal
right
for nations
now do you think this whole global
indigenous movement
has a place in the united nations
under the banner of universal right of
nations
can they be considered nations without
sovereignty
mike that's my point
gosh i yeah i'm not i'm not you know i'm
not
i don't i you know i don't think my my
findings speak to any of those questions
i mean they're important questions i'm
not sure i have anything
like terribly sophisticated to say about
them you know sometimes during the
colonial period
you know these the republic of the
indians was
it did have a form of sovereignty or
independence you know like the way the
colonial state operated it sort of
granted enormous autonomy to these
communities to kind of self-organize and
and
and you know that that's that's true you
know that's true all over the all over
the world i mean how how you recognize
that today in the modern world i don't
know i mean obviously that's that's
happening a lot in you know like there's
all of these people at least in bolivia
are and you know in chile now there's a
very interesting discussion in this
constitutional assembly about
indigenous people's rights and in
colombia after the 1991 constitution you
know indigenous people got rights to
their land they got kind of they got
mandated representation in national
political institutions they were kind of
recognized for the first time
but it's not you know that's not on the
same sort of scale as it is in bolivia
because you know indigenous people in
colombia are maybe like five percent of
the population so so i i
i don't know i'm not sure i must i'm
enough of a scholar to be able to answer
those questions i think i think
um you know i think you see indigenous
people everywhere gaining much more
recognition in australia look at what's
happening in canada in new zealand just
this week that maori people are
petitioning to change the name of the
country back to its original name away
from new zealand so i think you see that
sort of empowerment of indigenous people
everywhere and that sort of cultural
flourishing of indigenous people and i
you know maybe that's so much what i
think what you're suggesting there's a
much bigger picture here which this
research that i'm doing is kind of
sitting in this much bigger picture and
perhaps that that you know that helps
explain you know why it was that that
the mass were able to sort of grow and
and become empowered like this because
you know i mean it's very complicated
because they also
they also you know the morales is vice
president for example you know he was a
kind of marxist sociologist so they also
they tapped into this kind of
anti-neo-liberal
anti-washington consensus
kind of narrative as well but i mean
that's an interesting it's an
interesting question to ask you know and
i'd have to go and look at maybe at the
qualitative uh sources on this you know
is to what extent were they able to
tap into these broader narratives of
indigenous empowerment in a way that
helped them to kind of grow and flourish
i i'm not sure i know the answer to that
offer topic thank you for an interesting
answer
i see that daniel and gerard have their
hands up to daniel do you want to move
first
sure um my internet is a little unstable
so i hope you can hear me okay um i had
a quick question about the
interpretation of the moral economy as
is explaining the results
and because the like bolivia's main
cocoa growing regions the chaparrae and
are not necessarily the same places with
the strongest historical strength of the
ius so i wondered if you sort of
interpreted the moral economy as
happening equally in both the main
cohort growing areas as well as the ius
which i guess you could say the main
maybe coca consuming places um or is
there maybe a little more nuance between
between those two thanks so much
no i think i mean i think that what the
results that we like the best are the
ones with the iu you know because i
think sure you know uh you can't you
know you there's you know you play the
the main coca growing areas you know are
exactly where you described but people
are consuming the coke
everywhere and so so you know and it's
and it's kind of
embodied in people's lives everywhere
and so i think that's why we want that's
why i like these results with the iu
best you know that it's it's yeah
there's you know you could say in the
chat you know why is it that in the
chaparri valley the co you know the
cochlears got organized well their
livelihood was threatened you know
economically so so you know that that
that's part of the story
you know there's different you know
there's different things going on i'm
not saying it's the only thing that's go
that we're not saying this is the only
thing that's going on you know probably
the economic consequences of having your
crops
cut down you know there's other evidence
on that you know was important in
stimulating this organization of the
coca growers and whatever you know but
but but i think the iu results you know
is that you find this effect where
there's no you know it's not
coca-suitable they're not they're not
growing cocoa but they're using coca
intensively you know because it's so
much part of their lives and their
culture and their value system so i
think i think that is about the moral
economy but there's other things going
on also you know which as you say you
know if you're in maybe in the younger
you know when we do find these results
with coca-cola but places which are
coca-suitable outside the iu there's
also some kind of causal effect there
you know
for the usual kind of econometric
reasons we're not actually using
coca product you know the coca
production i mean we could do that but
but you know we that's we're using this
suitability because it seems to be more
more exogenous but perhaps we should
just check what happens we could check
what happens when you look at actual
production i don't know is that is that
did i answer that yeah you did and yeah
i i was wondering about the the coke the
actual cocoa production zones but you
know i understand the concerns but that
yeah it does sound like an interesting
check thanks
sure go ahead
hi jim um
one just one quick question i was
thinking about your results
and melissa's results kind of pulling
them one side by side and i guess
melissa has this story that has always
struck me as a little bit strange about
the haciendas actually being good
um because they are outside of the meet
and you know they are a good thing
that's basically
um and i suspect
presumably places with ius don't have a
sienna's at least formally
recognized if if the value is defined as
you know common land ownership
so i wonder
you should i mean then the effect could
come from the audio will come from the
from the absence of haciendas in a way
um i i wonder um
anyway i wonder how you think about this
right especially you know because
there's a lot more related to your idea
but the elites don't get their way all
the time right so if if the leaders are
the ones sitting on the haciendas and
this is happening in this land where
they actually don't have that much
purchase
um
yeah anyway i guess i'm thinking about
the other side of the living leaf that
you're running yeah so i mean i think
that's a complicated that's a
complicated issue and the re the reason
it's complicated is that bolivian is the
1952 bolivian revolution so in the
revolution after the revolution a lot of
haciendas got expropriated and
i
who'd lost land in the late 19th century
so the in the late 19th century in
bolivia there's a very typical latin
american story of expansion of export
crop production
kind of encroachment on
i don't know how this works in melissa's
context actually i never thought about
it but encroachment on traditional
indigenous lands and then after 1952
they sort of claimed this
back so we we've tried to find maps of
this but failed to actually i mean i
think what you're suggesting would be
extremely interesting to kind of look at
you know this interface between but like
you know rural bolivia today there's
more or less no haciendas left you know
they all were expropriated in 1952
and this land was sort of reclaimed by
these traditional communities so there's
a sort of interruption you know in the
first half of the 20th century for sure
and you know but we were and and you
know so that was that we thought was
interesting that would be an interesting
source of variation perhaps in how
cohesive these communities are you know
like a source of heterogeneity you know
that i think but we couldn't we went up
we were not able to really find a map or
some documentation that would allow us
to say you know here's an iu which
really you know and of course it's
difficult you know
here's an eye which really was an
enormous continuity and here's a place
where they were here they lost their
land in the 19th century and then it was
restored you know after this hacienda
was expropriated i mean if you go around
rural bolivia you find these abandoned
you know haciendas and things like that
or you find a hacienda with just like a
little garden around it or whatever that
lost everything but
we we haven't been able to do that
systematically systematically um
uh but we should we could you know now
you're suggesting that you know we did
have a long discussion about that at
some point but but but it didn't come to
a conclusion because we tried to find
data and
we we didn't succeed um
but i think you know like here the story
you know in some sense melissa story is
you know this income or this development
gradient is caused by good things
happening where the haciendas are
because asean does have political power
to kind of bring public goods and sort
of investment from the central
roads and you know connection to the
market et cetera that's basically that i
mean there's also effects on education
which i find more difficult to explain
without the enders but
but you know connection to the market
seems like a natural one um
maybe this thing is just not relevant by
the end of the 20th century anymore i
don't know i might
my gut react my gut reaction would be
it's not relevant but but pablo would
know more about that than me and and we
we should think we should think more
about it yeah we should think more about
that for sure
um so because we're running out of time
let me take one last question from
lucian and then we'll wrap up
neuron mute yeah oh thank you um
so i can't remember if
if the cocca suitability is
um vary over time in your regression so
i am saying that because there is this
paper um
from paola giuliano and netanyahu that
showed that okay um
um
ethnic group in places where
with high cla climatic stability they
tend to keep their tradition and their
culture so for for your um
for your result at least for your result
on indigenous name um
i'm wondering if
the caucus suitability is not varying
over time if it doesn't
pick like
the effect of climatic stability instead
so i don't know what you
have to say about that yeah i mean you
know the coco suitability is time
invariant so we you know we have this
fao data on
rainfall and
humidity and things like that so so it's
it's that that's a time invariant kind
of characteristic of this grid cell
i mean i know that paper you're talking
about but i'd have to think about how it
related to what we're
we're talking about i mean you could
sort of say if i thought about the kind
of long duray in bolivia you know maybe
indigenous that i would sort of say
you know it could be that there's
indigenous culture persists
differentially you know in some parts of
bolivia because of the mechanisms that
that nathan and paula are talking about
um so that would be you know it could be
i mean like i was talking with gerard
you know we had this idea that the
hacienda
if we knew where these haciendas were
which were then expropriated that would
actually give us a source of variation
in how cohesive these indigenous
communities are perhaps what you're
suggesting is that's another source of
variation if we knew something about
climatic variability that would actually
create a kind of prediction that you
know in some places because of climatic
variability that you know the indigenous
communities were kind of more cohesive
and and you know and that that should be
there should be a differential effect
you know so so that i mean that's an
interesting idea i hadn't thought about
that you know one of the most
interesting things about these bolivian
communities is this so-called
archipelago organization you know that
that because you have these i you know
you'll you know i'm trying to think of
this as related you know but because
you're in the altiplano but but you want
crops you know which grow in more
tropical regions so what they did was
they would send out like settlements of
people so one
settlement would actually one iu would
often have little kind of you know
little settlements down the mountainside
growing going chili peppers or growing
avocados or something like that which
didn't grow up in the altiplano and so
they'd engage in this enormous system of
reciprocity so they settled everywhere
again so that's actually i don't know
maybe that's something that could change
a lot if climate change or something
like that maybe that's less viable or
it's something you know which which you
could say modern spread of markets also
could change a lot we sort of thought
about that but again
you know where you where you get data on
that like you don't that's very hard to
understand you know it's very difficult
to get
data on that or measure it in a kind of
consistent way but i you know so i think
i think that's an interesting source of
variation but i haven't thought about it
so i haven't i couldn't i couldn't
i have no guess as to what the answer
would be yeah so jim along the same
lines have there been any significant
changes in the technology of cocoa
production that
you know interacts with the
growing conditions in any way
like makes them less relevant or more
relevant
over time
i think i mean i think that's certainly
true you know the story in colombia is
you know is that when the when pablo
escobar on the median drug cartel you
know they used to buy all the cocoa in
bolivia and peru
and then uh you know that but then they
decided they'd just start growing it in
colombia but the coca the type of coca
strains that grew in bolivia they wanted
to grow it at much lower altitudes in
these kind of the yenos like the
tropical plains in the east and and the
the stuff in chaparri and and
it was too high altitude you know so it
was too hot basically it were the
colombians so then they they did all
this kind of jeanette green engine it
was a green revolution in coca they
hired these scientists and basically
bred coca that was that flourished uh
you know so so that that's i you know i
don't know what that that's a story
that's in books about the median drug
cartel i don't quite know what the
evidence for that is but people tell
that story in colombia so that would be
sort of
that would suggest that maybe there is
you know there's some sort of mutability
in these these these conditions but i
don't quite know
we we could dig more into the side yeah
the fao
that's not the way the information is
presented in the fao data is that a
budgerigar on your shoulder oh yeah
okay i'm sorry
okay sorry it was putting me off uh
yeah so i i you know i
yeah what so i don't know i mean that
makes it even more surprising the
persistent effects of the immutable
portion of the conditions right
yeah i don't know you know i don't know
if that's happened in bolivia i mean we
should ask about that we should ask
about that i'm sure there's people who
would know in bolivia if that were true
and and
i don't know pablo might know but i i
yeah we we should we could ask about
that
okay well uh we're out of time so i want
to
let people go if they'd like if they
need to uh but jim thanks so much for
spending time with us um okay and it was
great to have you because it also
uh unsurprisingly brings together people
from different disciplines and
departments at yale so
okay yeah i'm very sorry i couldn't be
there in person that would have been
very fun yeah
all right uh and thanks everyone and
thanks uh teresa for organizing us as
usual thank you
okay
nice to see everyone thank you for
coming